hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of modeling the masters
I believe that the fastest and most
effective way to grow your business is
to model the strategies of people who've
already done what you're trying to do so
today we're going to look at the success
behind Coca Cola's ASIC handler and a
top three lessons that you can learn
from his success ASA Griggs Kammler was
born on December 30 1851 in Villa Rica
Georgia and was the eighth of eleven
children he grew up during a time with
the American Civil War
Chandler's father was a well-established
merchant and property owner but the war
would take its toll on the family they
often had no more than the bare
necessities handlers formal education
began when he was 5 years old
but was sporadic throughout when he was
10 years old he left school and spent
his time working on his father's farm
well it could have opted to attend Emory
College instead blood his brother Warren
attending his place
candolyn was anxious to enter the
working world he had an interest in a
medical field but with no money for
medical school he decided to pursue a
career as a druggist
he took off he took on an apprenticeship
with two pharmacists in his hometown but
his earnings were meager so kindly
decided to move to Atlanta in search of
better opportunities in 1873 with just a
dollar seventy-five in his pocket
Chandler made the move to Atlanta and
landed a job with a local druggist
George J Howard his early success and
work ethic led to his promotion as chief
clerk
however after falling out with Howard
Chandler decided to strike out on his
own and become his own boss Kamla used
to get migraines and one day they were
so bad that he was willing to try
whatever it took to get rid of it he
turned to a little-known product that
had been produced by fellow Atlanta
based druggist John Smith Pemberton
Pemberton had created something called
coca-cola his own personal fizzy brain
tonic and headache medication that
combined cocoa leaves and Kola nuts he'd
been selling a drink for five cents a
glass at his own drugstore it was
created in his backyard in a
three-legged fifteen gallon pot that
stood over a fire and when Cantler
sampled it he was immediately hooked
and what appeared to be a rash decision
to onlookers Kenley decided at once to
sell his entire stock of drugs paints
oils glass and fancy clothes he sold off
everything he could and raised roughly
$50,000 he initially invested five
hundred dollars in Pemberton's company
but by the end of 1891 he had managed
the ink control over the entire
coca-cola product for just twenty three
hundred dollars he use the rest of the
money to continue manufacturing and
marketing the drink coca-cola was born
action that I'm number one make people
remember your product many entrepreneurs
think that if they build a great product
sales would take care of themselves the
fact is an average product with great
sales and marketing will always help
perform an excellent product with no
sales and marketing you need to get the
word out about what you're doing or have
someone on your team do it for you
before Candler took over coca-cola
operations Pemberton had been doing
business on a small scale here at a
local company with a local customer base
and had little chances of growing up
much larger at the rate he was going his
only promotional effort was an aural
cloth with the sign drink coca-cola that
hung in the local drugstore Kayla
whoever knew that there were billions
more thirsty people out there he just
needed to find a way to reach them it
was through a strategy of aggressive and
memorable marketing initiated by canler
one which continues to this day
that coca-cola became the multi-billion
dollar company it is today according the
canler
I knew I had found something that other
people would want distributing coca-cola
through other pharmacies was a way to
reach more people I had to convince
other pharmacists to sell my drink
because they had their own drinks
option of them number to be unique your
customers are continually bombarded with
offers for products and services if you
want prospective customers to pay
attention to you you have to be unique
you need to do something that makes you
stand out from everyone else you may
know how great your product or services
but you have to convince your customers
that you're not just like everyone else
in 1820 british author charles coulton
wrote imitation is the sincerest form of
flattery but it is doubtful whether
canler would have agreed when the rising
popularity and success of coca-cola
became increasingly apparent to
outsiders
there was no short of of entrepreneurs
ready to take advantage
hundreds of copycat beverages were
released on the market within weeks the
need to protect this great product and
his strong brand work endless
motivations for ensuring both were
unique enough to stand out it was for
this reason a Kandla tried to focus
advertising around the authenticity and
originality of coca-cola from urging
customers to demand the genuine and
accept no substitute
Canela pushed the idea that only the
real coca-cola would satisfy your thirst
according to canler coca-cola was so
popular that many others were trying to
copy it because coca-cola was successful
I had to come up with an idea that would
make the product stand out from the
copycats the product sole itself I just
wanted to remind people it was one of a
kind action of number three if it ain't
broke don't fix it as entrepreneurs is
important to be continually testing
different aspects of your business try
and get better results make sure though
that you run your test on a small scale
and it beats out whatever is working
before we make a dramatic switch and how
you run your business coca-cola
executives in the 1980s would have done
well to follow in the example of its
founder in growing his company
Chandler understood the importance of
not messing with perfection as an
increasing number of copycat beverages
found their way into the market Kaler
might have changed the shape of his
bottle or altered his marketing message
but he never once made the crucial error
that his later successes would after
creating the perfect drink he never
again changed its secret recipe
Chandler knew that an increase in
competitive industry it was important to
stand out and to keep his customers on
their toes but he did not dare mess with
what he saw as excellence
after all it was not broke why fix it
however coca-cola executives tried to
replace the old with the new
as a result of launching new coke the
company's market share tanked candle was
proven right again changes sometimes bad
especially when you try and change the
perfect drink according the canler you
can change the marketing but never
change the drink
keeping the coca-cola recipe secret
meant it would always be unique ASA
canler was a strong business person and
aggressive when it came to all of his
ventures but he believed personal wealth
should benefit the community unheard of
in his day he would challenge other
wealthy business people to match
everything he gave to charity
a lot of his money went towards the
building of wesley Memorial Hospital
which is now known as Emory University
Hospital Candler did a lot for education
and is considered the founder of Emory
University according to one story he
would not associate with other
businesspeople that did not share his
point of view about giving back to the
community the feeling was proven in
public when he slapped one of the
richest men in Atlanta at the time for
not giving money to help expand Emory
University this story ran in all the
local newspapers and was front-page news
for more than a week until the wealthy
businessperson finally gave 12,500 to
the University and did it publicly
thank you for joining me for another
edition of modeling masters if you'd
like to be doing you want to see more
please give it a thumbs up below and if
you have a comment a question feel free
to leave it below I always like seeing
those come in so thank you and we'll see
you on the next episode
you